there there is something interesting
happening though in terms of you you
were talking about like the
indoctrination
about people just willing to go along
with whatever is being said something
interesting happened we have the story
from timcast.com jon stewart shocks
stephen colbert in rant about lab leak
being the most
rational explanation for kovid i know if
you guys saw this
but jon stewart appearing on the late
show with colbert
had colbert on on the defense colbert
trying to
stop jon stewart who was basically just
going off saying
he's like you come to me and tell me
there's a novel coronavirus that's
released
and you want to figure out where it came
from why don't we ask the lab that
literally works on the novel coronavirus
where it may have came from
and when you ask them hey where did this
come from they go maybe a bat
made it with a pangolin and you're and
this is john stewart
he gets up right into the camera colbert
desperately tries to make it seem
plausible that it wasn't china
this is what freaks me out a lot of
people have been saying like oh they
think we've been infiltrated by china
and their influence has taken over
mike pompeo said the chinese communist
party has infiltrated
every facet of government from city to
to local to state to federal government
and then you see this why is colbert so
desperate
he's like maybe the lab is there because
of all the bets bro there's no there's
no there's no bats there
they got the bats from hundreds of miles
away jon stewart is right
now this is interesting i don't know if
jon stewart will actually be a wake-up
call for regular liberals
maybe but jon stewart is is interesting
he's like he was frozen in carbonite
almost he's like han solo of our
generation right
back when he was still on the show he
was honest he praised project veritas
for their reporting
he would he would criticize obama when
obama was deserving of criticism
but he was a liberal he was a democrat
guy not necessarily democrat guy but you
know liberal
he leaves now he's coming back in the
lineup with a twitter account and all of
a sudden
the left is calling him a republican
colbert says when did you start
interning for ron johnson right that's
creepy
that's creepy level tribalism that jon
stewart doesn't exist in yeah it was
interesting too because the backlash on
twitter was
so severe against jon stewart saying
things that are not only completely
obvious but have been obvious for a long
time and that the washington post
recently had to completely walk back
everything that they said about the the
lab leak theory oh
i'll be fair to washington post in may
of last year they ran an op-ed talking
about lab leak
however as soon as the republicans
started saying it tom cotton they were
like oh this is a conspiracy and y'all
are nuts their take on today's issue was
pretty telling they wrote an article
an opinion piece that was titled john
stewart's rant as a reminder
don't rely on celebrities for covid 19
theories
meanwhile this is the same media
publication that a few months ago
had a headline article saying dwayne the
rock johnson
urges fans to wear masks after he and
his family get coveted 19
a real kick in the gut i mean obviously
these people don't have any morals don't
have any
objective stance on issues all of it a
lot of it is power a lot of it is ego
but but a lot of this is sociopathic
insane
criminal behavior in my opinion because
what jon stewart said
made absolute sense he brought and
concluded facts that
people were talking about for a very
long time that have been censored
away from the general public and stephen
colbert i don't know what they did to
him but they did something
because if you remember his show even on
comedy central he was hinting and
pointing at issues that were pretty
poignant that were pretty
populous that were pretty important i
remember even talking to him
about bilderberg which he knew a lot of
things about extensively
and now he's literally doing commercials
for big pharma promoting the vaccine
they're in one of the clips i don't know
if it was yesterday or the day before
but he released a video of him dancing
around with
with singing vaccines telling you how
you need to take the coven 19 vaccine
because it is safe it is effective
johnson and johnson are our heroes
pfizer is going to help you literally
it's a sick disgusting clip of him
dancing around here's and saying if
you're one of my family members you
don't take this vaccine you're not
welcome to any my events
it was it was repugnant to say the least
but but this is a man that literally
just
it looked like he was doing a commercial
for pfizer look
it's it's it's weird how the left has
become instantly pro
big pharma when they're always very
critical of it they've been pro big
pharma for a while i think i mean
the establishment i guess yeah i think
they have been if you look at go ahead
i was going to say um when it comes to
the vaccines the biggest issue i take
with
celebrities giving medical advice is
that they're going to write articles
saying don't do it
right they're they're saying oh john
stewart is exactly why i don't listen to
celebrities colbert's literally doing
it i have a friend who is dealing with
nerve damage
because we what we think happened was he
was given bad medical
advice what i guess what they're saying
is that
you you need a doctor to tell you if you
can get the vaccine for most people
there's no issues
but if you've had kovid within a certain
time frame there may be an adverse
reaction
don't ask don't don't come to me for
advice i'm telling you a story about my
friend you talk to your doctor to get
sound medical advice right i'll tell you
this
my my friend didn't get that advice he's
now learning about this after the fact
and he's dealing with nerve damage in
his arms and legs
i'm not trying to freak people out or
playing any conspiracy or anything
anything like that i'm just saying maybe
you shouldn't go to stephen colbert
or joe rogan for your medical advice
maybe if jon stewart wants to make a
political point about a lab in china has
nothing to do
with whether or not he's advising you to
take medication yeah they want to come
out and claim that joe rogan
for for making his comments about
vaccines saying if you're young is what
joe rogan said he said if you were young
you shouldn't get it
i don't think joe should be giving
advice i don't think dr fauci should
either
because regular people have very
specific medical needs their doctor
needs to inform thereof
inform them of so if colbert is going to
come out and do a commercial for big
pharma and vaccines
it's on the same level as joe rogan
doing the same thing you need to talk to
a doctor and if you don't like their
opinion you get a second opinion you get
a third opinion
and i always tell people this make sure
you're not getting a political opinion
i think that's important and i but i do
think that the left has been
shilling for big pharma for quite a long
time they're very interested in
promoting all kinds of drugs and turning
children who are
gender dysphoric into lifelong medical
patients
this has been going on for quite a while
they were pushing the
antidepressants for kids and pushing the
you know
focused medication for kids they've been
doing this for decades how can
how can anyone trust big pharma after
the opioid epidemic
that ripped through and destroyed middle
america that that is still causing
severe effects i mean but it's not just
the democrats it's also the republicans
i mean donald trump wanted
to call the coven 19 vaccine the trump
scene and he's the one
that authorized emergency uh use of this
he's the one
that pushed for this he's the one that
wanted you know to be congratulated by
pfizer
but you also had kamala harris and
andrew cuomo both saying in the fall
that they were skeptical
they were skeptical of the vaccines and
then as soon as joe biden becomes
president
it's you know everybody roll up your
sleeve can i just uh
read a story for you guys go for it this
is from the guardian
friday 23 may 2003 bayer division
knowingly sold
hiv infected protein yup so i i
i'll put it this way look i'm not a
doctor
i don't have all the answers uh i can't
tell people what to do that's why i
always say you gotta go to a doctor
there are a lot of people that tell me
like oh i don't trust my doctor and i'm
like dude if you don't trust your doctor
then i don't know who you trust
like you go to a different doctor and
you don't trust them the fact is when i
go to the doctor and they prescribe me
some weird name
i don't know what that is i'll google it
to look it up because ultimately you're
responsible for your own health
but we're talking about massive
multinational corporations and they're
more concerned with their bottom line
they don't exist to save you they exist
to make money and sell a product
when we can look at history and see
bayer knowingly sold hiv infected
protein
i think it's fair to say you're not
you're allowed to be skeptical of
massive multinational corporations
well you should be skeptical of that of
course across the board no matter what
it is that they're selling yeah
well they're criminal institutions if
you look at some of the big pharma
agencies i don't even want to mention
because i don't want to get anyone in
trouble but if you look at some of the
big pharma agencies that are behind some
of the medical procedures here
a lot of them have been previously
charged with bribery corruption have
been heavily fined and have been caught
buying off doctors to push for policies
along with politicians that
mainly benefited them and when you look
at i mean a lot of people
really do not understand the severity of
the opioid epidemic and the level
of horrendous horrible addictions that
it caused
all throughout middle america and that
story is under reported significantly
because
if you even just drive around you see
entire cities
with doctors that were paid off that
absolutely
ravaged and destroyed them from the from
the very up i got i got to read the
story sorry i don't
know and interrupt but uh luke brought
the story before we started
from abc news 899 people got expired
vaccine doses at times square site
health officials say
899 people received expired covered 19
vaccine doses
okay i they just repeat the headline but
anyways from the eights from abc news
reporting from the ap and that's
basically it they say atc vaccination
services the company that administered
the shots under contract to the city
said in a statement we apologize for the
inconvenience to those receiving the
vaccine
in question and want people first and
foremost to know that we have been
advised that there is no danger from the
vaccine they received
that's good news i think what they're
saying is that basically it's just
ineffective like because it was expired
people basically
the inspired part was like it was thawed
for too long is that the idea i don't
i don't know exactly well maybe but the
the reason i read the story is
i don't like the idea that we do these
like in front of 7-eleven medical
you know uh procedures it's like there's
a reason why you go to a doctor and ask
for advice
they go to school for this they're not
perfect people they're regular people
but they specialize in certain fields
you don't like their opinion you can
always get a second opinion
but when you show up to one of these
like this was a pop-up in times square
that was the former nfl experience
this is literally it and the employees
there couldn't
look at the expiration date which is on
the product i mean
that just how can you people have trust
i i i i'm thinking
i think you're on to something too you
know like you're saying you know it's
it's important to have a relationship
with your doctor and it's important to
consult your doctor and make a decision
yeah that's and this is coming from a
canadian you know i think
americans there's a certain decadence to
the superiority of the american medical
system from
any other in the world and and
it's i think it's lost on a lot of
americans you know big pharma
and i'm not disagreeing with anything
you're saying about the opioid epidemic
is horrific
and there have been so many there have
been so many issues with big pharma and
i'm not like you know i've heard the
stories and i'm not discounting them and
that's important and fair
but there's also a level of personal
responsibility that comes into
taking medication you know and i'm not
blaming people who are addicted to
heroin for their addiction to heroin but
but i mean well i should say i'm not
blaming what
all i'm trying to say is big farm big
farm is important
big pharma cures cancer big pharma you
know
finds polio vaccines too you know
they're not just
pushing a sketchy rushed you know well
that was that was
salk right he gave it away for free
didn't he he did yeah
but it just means that he did not hold
that like there's something to be said
for a privatized
drug industry because the amount of r d
the amount of break like
the breakthroughs that come out of the
united states are what keeps the into
the rest of the world
yeah i i i i think there's something to
be said you're right just
weighing what you're taking but not
necessarily demonizing the people just
making whatever and trying to sell it
yeah yeah yeah i think you know what i'm
going to walk by those statements say
big pharma is
our friend um we should never criticize
them ever in any way i just i'm kidding
i don't mean that i just mean that they
don't deserve all the flack
you know no they they do they they
deserve to at least be held accountable
and they haven't been because they've
been getting slaps on the wrist and just
small fines compared to their profits
for the horrible things that they did
yes
they do some good things but but when
you allow big companies to get away with
such
horrendous treacherous acts where people
who are unsuspecting people who are
trusting people who believe in the
establishment get punished the most for
it
you need some ramifications where the
executive who made sure that the hiv
strain got out there because he wanted
to make a buck
that he he goes to jail not that his
company gets a slap on the wrist gets a
little bit of money he needs to be
personally held responsible for his
actions and none of that has happened
you know of course i think you don't
think pharmaceutical companies could be
like
limited liability companies are they
what is the law regarding
big pharma has no liability when it
comes to this vaccine so if you you take
it you get hurt
all the responsibility afterwards is on
you as an individual what about that's a
correct what about
other corruptions exactly and there
hasn't been any big ramifications with
that entire industry that have been
significant and that's why they keep
doing it and unless you hold them
accountable they're going to do another
opioid epidemic because they got away
with it in the first place
a lot of that's i think is also on the
insurance companies of course and we've
seen a complete
you know decimation of the whole health
insurance situation with the aca because
i don't know if you guys have ever
bought your insurance on any of the
um you know aca exchanges
but it's like every year you buy a plan
and then at the end
and then you like try and figure out
what doctors take it you try and figure
out what your deductible is which is
usually ridiculous
you can't actually ever get to a doctor
it takes a long time to get an
appointment and then the following year
it turns out your plan has been
discontinued and you have to buy
something else
and every time you have to go through a
whole qualification process
like i just i was trying to buy
insurance this year and it turned out to
be like they want income verification
and i work for a canadian company and
i'm like i don't even have what you
want wow yeah that's weird yeah the
whole system and then they put my sons
and they were like oh this is connected
to your son's
you know state plan because he's on like
child health plus with new york state
which i'm happy about
but now they're trying to link that and
they're like i need income verification
for that and i'm like
no like just insure my kid i'm paying
you thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you